réponse en quelque sorte du ministre
chargé du dossier au sein du
gouvernement jean farges c'est une
défense et illustration du ticket
modérateur
jean faure répondait aux questions de
jean marc il use le gouvernement ne sont
ce pas à revenir sur cette mesure pas
plus que sur aucune autre du plan de
redressement financier d'ascq et et
sociale qui l'a mise en oeuvre et je
voudrais profiter de votre question pour
apporter certaines précisions sur ce
qu'est en réalité ce ticket modérateur
d'ordre public
d'abord il ne s'applique aux seuls
assurés sociaux qui sont payeur assez
nombreux qui bénéficient d'une
couverture complémentaire de celle de la
sécurité sociale pc tools est ouverture
complémentaire soit le fait de mutuelle
ou soit le fait de compagnies
d'assurance c'est un premier point
deuxième point ce ticket modérateur
d'ordre public ne concerne que je dirais
les dépenses courantes de santé par
exemple les dépenses d'hospitalisation
qui sont dans la très grande majorité
des gars prise en charge à 100% par la
sécurité sociale
resteront présents sont à sont prises en
charge à 100% par la sécurité sociale
troisième point ce ticket modérateur a
pour objet de laisser une certaine
participation de l'assuré à ses dépenses
courantes de santé de manière à le
sensibiliser à ce beaucoup de ses
dépenses mais c'est une participation
très modérée de l'ordre de 5%
du coup de ses dépenses de santé